hello and welcome to this video playing
Alexa oh my god what kind of scores that
and minus six that's that's not good
okay so probably the red team purely
take on d5 and almost all variations
including this one yeah okay and now d
for coming up ah ok yeah this is a nice
position for white I think and I have
this this is important trick Knight c3
that's 94 played immediately didn't you
think about it okay
maybe he knew this line okay what about
this directly attacking directly
attacking you to him
hmm that's not so easy to play what to
do and II to hangs it just hangs I
wonder about f5 possibly no I don't
think f5 I have rupee one Queen H will
be won't take a sick so I think would be
one right maybe he just goes back and
then I'm still in this bloody bloody
situation here so quinte to right 22 ok
queen e five that's 95
maybe I'm not losing material if my
position is quite nice because this is
just a boatload of weaknesses but yeah
maybe there is / there are enough
concrete problems but 95 no right to be
aware of all else trickier this trickery
here
that looks that looks troublesome for
black if it takes it Bishop takes that
doesn't look good and where would you go
with the night to before no add this one
okay hmm I don't like to trade Quincy
and this position really not when rookie
one should be better for white but it's
I don't want to trade stuff really not
hmm
have a good square though okay not ideal
okay okay 93 really 93 no okay took and
now i guess the night move taking only
four looks pretty terrible night before
maybe so like a 393 don't have and take
a five next and c6 should work 95 maybe
or h6 may be h6e our room I don't want
to now probably have to go back ahead
seems to it seems to just hang on by a
thread this this whole position Bishop
everyone maybe now come on i th three I
didn't want to go there but maybe it is
what I have to do
yeah so he takes f 9 p-3 a book before I
look the six maybe look the 6-pound a
better looking at e six as well Bishop
c6 is the first threat and the second
one is taken is six
yeah it should be good
you
yeah seems good yeah don't really see a
good move here for black it's got some P
should beat or something along these
lines this one okay I'm taking here
right f4 might even come in handy here
we cannot place you file a late c4 maybe
94
I'd see form and what would have been
interesting Bishop g4 night f2 is good
for white I think guys out of all of
resources I think the land hunting
reasons I was a difference challenge
here okay a tough game usually quite
quite challenging he played that very
actively this is what I actually
recommended in my English repertoire
series I'm very sure I remember this
this this is really putting putting
putting me into some it asks questions
that have to be answered probably very
correctly otherwise i meant problems ok
this is the engine move and ok Queen 95
is what the engine gives I was afraid of
this move tween d6 and winning Wow jack
yeah okay the bishop has no squeals yeah
that's probably the thing not
threatening this and this in some cases
okay well it's a computer you know so
that was a lot stronger that means now
let's see if I basically wins the game
he has to go back to ca then ok I didn't
find it and he has to take and play 93
which is still acceptable for black yes
ok and now i'm just curious if I'm
plated correctly if form must be right
and yeah Queen our queen d14 Queen h5 ah
that's good yes for now
I didn't see that Queen h5 is coming
here okay that was stronger I mean this
just keeps a pretty big edge but it's
not as good as the other line yeah so
I'm okay yeah org or computer move f4
wasn't the best but keeps keep the
advantage yeah I'm reasonably happy I
could have played a bit better in one or
two key positions but it was really okay
I think he's a good opponent I mean I've
got a terrible score so I'm happy to
have gotten to win in here okay thanks
for watching